Taka, it certainly seems that we have a good working relationship.
I feel the same.
We understand now that the goals of both companies seem to be aligned,...
...and that our products could work in a complementary way.
This could create a very valuable solution for our customers.
I think we should move forward with a partnership in which we develop business together.
I am pleased to hear this. I agree completely!
Of course, we need to have more detailed discussions on the products from the engineering perspective.
Yes, in terms of technical issues,...
...we need to involve engineering teams from both companies.
Why don't we plan another meeting to focus on technical integration issues?
That's exactly what I was thinking.
We need to have that engineering meeting as soon as possible.
How about scheduling a conference call next week after you get back to Japan, Taka?
Ok. I'll talk with the engineering department right away,...
...and suggest a few possible dates and times.
Sounds good. I'll coordinate a meeting with the engineering team on my side.